a new CBS News poll shows Americans are
sharply divided about president Trump's
executive order on immigration 36% say
the travel ban will make the country
safer from terrorism the same number say
it will make us less safe mr. Trump's
Supreme Court pick 27% say the Senate
should confirm Neal Gorsuch 14% say no
56% say they can't say for this poll we
began calling Wednesday we got the
results overnight people want to know
how we conduct these surveys so we asked
CBS News elections director Anthony
salvato to take us behind the scenes
hello my name is sandy Miller when I see
so many idiots I'm calling on behalf of
CBS News with the poll on current events
today CBS News poll started right here
in Allentown Pennsylvania and in phone
rooms just like this one all across the
country we're over a hundred
interviewers dial phone numbers randomly
to people all over America do you think
of yourself as liberal moderate or
conservative the phone numbers randomly
generated by a computer include both
landlines and these days mostly cell
phones are on Ben poureth oversees this
phone center that makes the calls for
CBS News Iran how many numbers do we
typically have to dial to do a CBS poll
well to get a thousand interviews such
as we're gonna get on this poll we
probably need to dial twenty thousand
numbers everyone who takes the poll is
included in the results Carole DeVault
from Derby Kansas is a trump supporter
who took today's when I voted for Donald
Trump it was a matter of hope that
things would change and as far as what
he's doing now so far I'm in favor of
the things he's been doing we call
people from all 50 states but key to a
good poll is that it looks like a
cross-section of America we call enough
people so that the poll does that which
statistically happens by the time we get
to a thousand people we made sure that
the poll matches the US census on
demographics like age talking to both
young and the old and everyone in
between on gender talking to women and
men and the correct proportions by race
also that the poll reflects this that
Mystikal makeup of the united states we
talked to Democrats Republicans and
independents and remember all polls have
a margin of error for any number you see
there's a range around it if you don't
talk to enough people that range around
any given number starts to get wider you
don't want to thank you questions even
by way of explanation we never want to
skip questions and assume answers the
questions these interviewers are asking
are focused on the news of the day so
today it's the Supreme Court pick and
the travel ban do you approve or
disapprove of temporarily banning
refugees from entering the United States
the goal is for us to word the questions
to be unbiased so that people of all
different views feel like they have a
choice
I took the poll last night because I
believe that if we're given an
opportunity to express ourselves as
Americans that we should do that thank
you for your participation sir and you
have a wonderful evening sir polls are
not predictions they're what people
think today
so when you see poll numbers move
remember there are people on the other
end of those numbers and sometimes
people just decide to change their mind
and if you ever wonder why didn't they
call me
well odds are we talked to someone just
like you or at least someone who agrees
with you did the polls miss something in
2016 I actually know there were plenty
of Trump voters in the polls in 2016 but
many of the Trump voters came late so
they were undecided voters there was a
big shift over to him late in the
campaign his campaign was able to turn
out more of his voters all of which
comes back to this idea that people can
change their minds and that's one of the
people came late wins what well the
undecided voters who switched over to
Trump late in those final 10 days really
made the difference and we saw a swing
of the undecided there that was bigger
than than anything we'd seen before
there probably should have seen it
coming
well I know actually that was part of
the big surprise it wasn't that people
were left out of the polls it was that
he was trailing and then his campaign
did a remarkable job of coming back were
marked as undecided in that period after
you were telling us it's harder you're
starting to actually move polling more
online because when it's harder to reach
people by phone now oh absolutely it's
getting harder
and one of the things that online can do
is give people a chance to take it
whenever it's convenient for them you
can do it when you're at home you can do
it on your phone etc and it's as
reliable oh yeah absolutely so therefore
more accurate it can be yeah Anthony
Silva thanks so much room with us